you changed your media exactly diet
habits right so what changes did you
make there are little tricks you can do
you can set up times where your phone
will shut off certain apps you can turn
your phone onto grayscale which is
actually incredibly helpful at making it
less addictive it doesn't take away too
much from it I think that social media
is giving that you're finding addictive
is the feeling of validation the feeling
of connection the feeling of having a
community whose support maybe you're
getting or not getting but you were
definitely chasing and if you can
replace that with you know a group of
Runners a group that you go cycling with
or what I did and just had a big like
group chat that I check in with 30 times
a day instead of checking Facebook and
Twitter 30 times a day it will supplant
the need that is driving you to the
social platforms and I think that will
take care of a lot of the downstream
effects of how it's changing your
politics how it's changing your
emotional violence it sounds so bad it
sounds like they couldn't possibly be
the answer but I think it really is